salut salut salut joyeux 11 avril à
toutes et à tous juste avant que la
vidéo commence je vous donne les
dernières de spectacle de création parce
que la tournée se termine je suis à lens
le 3 mai fourmies c'est à côté de la
belgique en création passe pas par la
belgique mais je suis quand même à côté
le 4 mai à dunkerque le 5 à 2 1 à côté
de valenciennes le 6 mai à lille 2 7 mai
à palavas et montpellier le 20 mai
candidats ne vient jamais à montpellier
je suis à palavas genève le 2 juin
marseille le 17 juin des ensembles 30
juin le yen à la description le pompidou
aujourd'hui on va continuer sur un
deuxième épisode des syndromes étrange
du cerveau j'ai cru que vous aviez
beaucoup aimé la première vidéo sur le
sujet j'ai donc décidé de faire des
recherches sur des syndromes encore plus
surprenant est pourtant pas si rare je
vais vous raconter l'histoire d'un
coréen kim vieilli pas d'un jeune garçon
qui avait peur de perdre son pénis année
où areva attend beaucoup trop rien à
regretter c'est pas drôle d'ami dans le
quotidien mais bon il n'ya pas que ça
donc c'est parti pour cette syndrome shu
le communisme
lui nommé le toit on avait fait 10 était
un petit peu long on peut en faire huit
mettant faire toi même aujourd'hui tu
dois t'en faire ça ce serait bien celle
où le syndrome de type prend pour fabien
olicard tu fais un syndrome
loïc génériques
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en premier le syndrome de north et vous
aimez les animaux les petites boules de
poils qui nous réconforte le soir et
bien il y en a pour qui ça pose un
véritable problème est là vous allez me
dire pourquoi merci d'avoir posé la
question côté je veux dire c'est bien
parce que il les aime un peu trop ou
plutôt il les aime mal ça a l'air de
partir sur un truc chelou mais c'est
moins chez lui que ce que vous pensez
qu'il y a des personnes qui accumulent
chez elles toutes sortes d'animaux et
accumulé c'est le mot ce syndrome c'est
une forme de ti loghmani un phénomène
des crimes location compulsif qu'on
retrouve notamment dans le syndrome de
diogène je vous en avais parlé dans la
première vidéo tant les personnes
entassées multitude de déchets et bella
c'est pareil mais c'est des animaux donc
du coup on comprend bien d'où vient le
nom du syndrome en référence à l'arche
de noé et voulait voir ce que ça donne
en images ça j'aime ça alors le souci si
qu'avec toutes ces bestioles la personne
est dans l'incapacité de s'en occuper
des nourrir convenablement
donc ça devient pas de maltraitance en
fait parce que les animaux vivent dans
des conditions misérables
d'ailleurs en france est considéré comme
de la maltraitance même si c'est pas
l'intention première de des personnes
ces animaux parfois finissent par mourir
de faim question je te la faire là
julien lepers attention question un
indice au bas de votre écran à votre
avis combien d'animaux et femmes
atteintes de ce syndrome a pu héberger
dans 1 40 mètre carré non c'est non
c'est plus 74e chien 32 hamster des
chats des tortues des lapins plus
étonnant encore oui c'est possible une
personne qui avait cumulé 130 chat dans
un logement de 25 mètres carrés ah ouais
ouais ouais ouais oui je sais même pas
où elle dormait avec tous ses charmes et
pour la petite fun fact eleanor à berne
ati dans les simpsons et atteintes de ce
trouble on l'appelle la fois lochard
brasse et 2e syndrome le syndrome de
highlander et oui hors jeu que j'ai
jamais connu la suite je crois qu'on a
déjà tous rêvé un jour de ne jamais
vieillir et encore je suis pas sûr se
référer à la vidéo du 30 décembre 2021
qu'on a fait avec loïc en tout cas c'est
ce qui arrive à guillaume yunxi un jeune
coréen de 26 ans qui libéra le monde ne
vieillit plus sa croissance ça s'est
arrêté juste avant la puberté du coup il
a toujours l'apparence d'un garçon de 13
ans c'est un peu incroyable ça sorte le
mental est tout à fait normal par contre
y'a pas de problème il fait sa vie comme
n'importe quel jeune homme de 26 ans il
se rend boîte il boit de l'alcool j'ai
envie de m'en de sa carte d'identité à
chaque fois encore plus troublant brooke
greenberg une américaine qui a atteint
de ce syndrome qui paraissent ces deux
ans à l'âge de 20 ans c'est incroyable
alors elle l avait plus de problème
parce que contrairement à notre ami
coréen à laver un retard mental le
chercheur richard est folle coeur
explique que chez certaines personnes il
arrive que le processus de développement
soit retardé et que le changement du
corps soient ralentis ce syndrome reste
tout de même difficilement explicable à
ce jour et pour cause ils sont seulement
quatre dans le monde à vivre avec ce
phénomène étrange et richard falk heures
qui étudie beaucoup ce syndrome a pas
mal d'espoir pour eux ils espèrent
trouver le jeune actrice pensable de ce
phénomène pour appuyer sur le bouton
stop du vieillissement du corps pays
donc ça serait pas le troisième syndrome
ileos loïc du coup c'est mon tour allez
on est chaud
un petit rigoles ou quoi
mais bon elle et c'est à mon tour donc
le syndrome de huntington gulf oil waouh
ça va très très vite
on va remonter un petit peu voilà alors
que son nom est fabien franc peu plus
haut un syndrome presque irréelle digne
du film l'étrange histoire de benjamin
button cet homme qui est né vieux et qui
rajeunit toute sa vie on observe whaou
on observe
et puis ça le fait de chiens rires
[Rires]
non mais c'est bien faux expérience se
réchauffe soi même pour se rendre marque
chez ces patients un vieillissement
accéléré avec des symptômes qui débute
très jeunes entre 18 et 24 mois bon
allez c'est bon je lai là je suis rentré
un peu dans le personnage du fab où la
personne commence à ressembler à une
personne âgée avec des rides une peau
fine des pertes de cheveux avec tous les
problèmes qui vont avec douleurs
articulaires problèmes cardiaques etc le
phénomène est ultra rare puisqu'il
touche entre 100 et 200 personnes dans
le monde trois cas en france ce syndrome
est déclenchée par la mutation d'un gène
ali hussein cannes et maintenant je
comprend les noms à chaque fois qu'il
faut dire c'est ok un indien de 14 ans
mène ce combat difficile qui l'a
d'ailleurs déjà perdu cinq frères et
soeurs du même syndrome dont le plus âgé
a vécu jusqu'à 24 ans alors que
généralement l'espérance de vie pour ces
gens-là et de 13 ans un cas un peu plus
connu est celui de rania elle a réussi à
vivre jusqu'à 16 ans et du coup elle a
dépassé l'espérance de vie de cette
maladie mais ensuite elle s'est
malheureusement éteint de vieillesse à
16 ans c'est triste mais c'est le propre
de cette maladie qu'on vieillit très
rapidement
4 le syndrome de coraux alors là c'est
un sujet qui va particulièrement touché
les hommes et leurs précieux attributs
dont ils sont si fiers apparemment en
une phrase les hommes atteints par ce
syndrome ont une très profonde que leur
pays se rétracte dans l'abdomen ils
disparaissent à tout jamais je rigole
mais c'est un vrai trouble et ça doit
être relou d'avoir ce syndrome alors
cette crainte particulièrement présente
en asie est un trouble qui décrit comme
étant culturel de rares cas ont été
rapportés chez des noms asiatiques mais
c'est plus rare il semblerait même selon
certaines sources qu'une épidémie de
coraux aurait eu lieu en 1967 à
singapour il y avait une étrange rumeur
qui avait émergé selon laquelle la
consommation de viande de porc
empoisonné pouvait provoquer ce
phénomène de rétractation du pénis dans
l'abdomen une vague de panique s'était
propagé jusqu'à ce que le ministère de
la santé a rassuré la population dans
les médias en disant que c'est un état
purement psychologique moi j'hésite
vraiment 10 de la santé par oui vous
inquiétez pas votre pénis va rester oui
bonjour votre pénis restera présente oui
bonjour à votre pénis et mondiaux et
leur entraîneur je déconne il est
toujours là bon rien de plus à rajouter
là-dessus on peut continuer avec un
autre syndrome qui là aussi est culturel
en sac le syndrome du voyageur puis il
ya ces étonnants vous avez déjà peut
être visité paris florence jérusalem ou
l'inde et peut-être que vous avez
ressenti un petit un petit phénomène
étrange parfois quand tu visites un
endroit tu es un peu transcendé par le
lieu en fait et ça c'est ce qui arrive
et pas mal de voyageurs alors quel
phénomène me direz vous eh bien il ya
des personnes qui lorsqu'elle visite
jérusalem par exemple se mettent à
délirer halluciné à proclamer des
serments à se prendre elle même pour des
prophètes etc
et d'après le docteur hier darel ces
crises sont liés à de la déception c'est
incroyable en fait certaines personnes
qui rêvent d'aller à jérusalem depuis
des années très très fort ça représente
pour eux un pèlerinage une fin en soi et
forcément quand on rêve de quelque chose
on valide et alizée sauf qu'une fois
arrivés sur place ils se rendent compte
que la réalité ne colle pas vraiment
avec leurs fantasmes qui avait depuis
des années al'inverse à peu aussi hier
d'un bouleversement d'une émotion très
forte en présence de certains monuments
liés aux croyances ou pas d'ailleurs il
ya un touriste canadienne s'est passé
par là bas et qu'ils pensaient être la
réincarnation moderne de samson le
personnage biblique il s'est donc mis
naturellement à vouloir abattre le mur
des lamentations à manu c'est gênant on
a un peu le même délire avec tahri ou
les touristes plus particulièrement les
japonais font face à un fossé entre ce
qu'ils avaient imaginé de paris est le
vrai pari les médias japonais ont
tendance à véhiculer une image un peu
trop fantasmer notre capitale paris
romantique et les grands et puis là tu
descends dans le métro petits découvrent
dans le petit accordéon il manque ton
portefeuille ça sent pas toujours très
bon bienvenue à paname et même plus
simplement le fait qu'ils aient en face
d'eux des gens pressés une ville
bruyante ça c'est un choc c'est un
véritable choc culturel certains cas
peuvent mener à des hospitalisations
voir un rapatriement quand même et
parfois ça va plus loin avec des délires
paranoïaques olivia gotoh greget une
psychologue clinicienne à paris raconte
qu'un jour un touriste ne sortait plus
de sa chambre d'hôtel depuis trois jours
je crois persuadé de devoir déchiffrer
un code il se croyait victime d'une
conspiration visant à l'éliminer
regardez les informations boucle sur bfm
et nous n'y comprenais pas ce qui se
disait ça aussi ça peut m'arriver mois
loïc ans à coucou coucou coucou
la psychologue explique aussi qu'en
france on se fait la bise les gens en
pose des questions intimes au japon à la
première rencontre on se tient à
distance on on compare le pas de
politique par exemple ça c'est vulgaire
ça mais les gens mal à l'aise donc si
c'est pas les mêmes codes sociaux le
phénomène est étonnant mais il existe
bel et bien même s'il se fait rare ce
syndrome pourrait d'ailleurs mérité une
vidéo entière à lui tout seul en sixième
on parle du syndrome de peter pan vous
avez peut-être déjà entendu parler on
sait déjà tous dit en tant qu'adulte
c'était bien quand j'étais enfant pas de
responsabilité et pas d'impôts par une
affaire en battant s'occupe de nous
voilà ça c'est bien mais il ya des
personnes qui refusent complètement de
grandir pour que c'est terminé
concrètement ça se traduit par points eh
bien ces personnes se réfugient dans un
monde imaginaire à travers des jeux des
jeux vidéo des films etc pour trouver un
échappatoire à leur vie d'adulte il n'a
rien pris
et alors du coup bah ya une difficulté à
développer des amitiés profondes des
trucs d'adultes quoi une incapacité à
assumer des responsabilités
les difficultés à exprimer ses émotions
ce syndrome le syndrome de peter pan
apparaît généralement entre 20 et 25 ans
et touche principalement les hommes on
peut surtout se demander d'où ça vient
et il ya plusieurs possibilités c'est
pas toujours évident de déceler la vraie
cause parmi elles on à l'absence d'un
père un rôle trop important en tant
qu'enfant avec de grandes
responsabilités un besoin d'assumer de
trop lourd de responsabilités ou encore
un manque d'amour quand on est petit
quoi qu'il en soit la psychothérapie est
une solution cette le syndrome dans
brasse si vous pensez que votre père
votre compagnon vous même était la
personne la plus poilu de la terre vous
êtes loin de la vérité est ce que vous
connaissez pedro gonzalez il était très
un peu entrer beaucoup plus il était
atteint 10 paires tricot pilosité
anormalement abondante dans cette
maladie on retrouve une sous-catégorie
une forme plus grave nommé le syndrome
lembras qui se caractérise par la
présence de poils longs sur le visage et
sur le corps pour la petite anecdote les
personnes atteintes de ce syndrome dans
le siècle précédent gagner leur vie dans
les cirques itinérants ou dans des
spectacles qui mettait à l'honneur des
personnes avec certaines particularités
physiques ou des malformations bon pas
d'inquiétude c'est une maladie très rare
qui est due à une anomalie génétique et
justement on va voir dans le prochain
syndrome ce que ça donne quand on a une
anomalie d'ordre digestif 8e le syndrome
de l'odeur du poisson pourri cela peut
paraître étonnant j'ai pas ce syndrome
et j'ai la peur permanente d'avoir ce
syndrome depuis des années que je le
connais parce que c'est bien réel il y à
des personnes qui souffrent d'un
syndrome assez dérangeant qui les
marques d'une odeur corporelle très
forte une odeur de poisson pourri et moi
dès que je transpire jeu ça s'emballe
poisson ou quand ça sent le poisson
départ je sais pas moi
kelly une anglaise de 39 ans souffre de
ce syndrome et a décrit sa propre
d'heure comme un mélange entre du
poisson et des oignons elle a commencé à
voir les premiers signes de ça durant
son enfance et une intensification à
l'adolescence elle a mis plusieurs
années à diagnostiquer et aujourd'hui
tout va bien le prendre des médicaments
pour améliorer sa qualité et vite et
celle de ses proches par la même
occasion même si c'est pas de sa faute
mais d'où ça vient ça pour ça il faut
comprendre un petit peu le mécanisme de
la digestion quand vous mangez un
aliment c'est un aliment est imbibé de
sucs gastriques qui passent dans
l'intestin ou les digérer lors de ce
processus le corps va libérer des
substances dont la tri mais si la mine
alors dans un corps sain cette substance
malodorantes et détruite par une petite
enzymes à bien la bouffe et la détruit
et c'est cette enzyme qu'ils déconnent
chez certaines personnes et qui du coup
va provoquer cette odeur malodorante
alors il ya un point positif si c'est
qu'il est possible d'y faire quelque
chose on peut éliminer les aliments qui
favorise la production de ce crime et y
la mine comme le poisson ou là y compris
c'était assez évident mais aussi des
oeufs le lait encore le chou et là haut
dit bête pourquoi tu finis par ce
syndrome en 8 parce que c'est sympa de
finir sur une note positive et de se
dire que quand même il ya des solutions
au syndrome dont je vous parle de temps
en temps moi j'espère que cette vidéo
vous a plu et surtout que le fait que je
fasse un deuxième épisode ça faisait
plus haut si vous l'avez pas mal
demander dans les commentaires de la
première donc j'ai fait donc même
mécanique si vous en voulez un troisième
et si elle contenue et bienfaisance à
vous me le dites et vous abonner en même
temps vous mettez le petit pouce en
l'air quant à moi je m'appelle toujours
fabien ce cycle a renoncé faut c'est
fabien olicard mon nom ici je vous mets
deux autres vidéos le sel sur les seins
donc je loue du cerveau et une autre
vidéo celle ci c'est sur un matière
grise si vous connaissez pas ce format
il est très intéressant n'oubliez pas
que la fin de la tournée en création ça
se termine fin juin j'aurai fait 55
représentations dans 55 villes vous avez
toute la liste des villes qui reste
justifie si c'est pas encore complet
vous avez le lien dans la description et
on se voit évidemment après les
spectacles prenez soin de vous à très
bientôt ciao